hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game from round eight of
the London chess classic the game was
played between Magnus Carlsen and Ayana
pommy Oishi and I'm sure you all heard
about Paul Murphy you know what's the
first first thing that pops into your
mind when you think Paul Morphy probably
you know chess God the greatest chess
force of that era but even the great
Paul Morphy had a nemesis that he simply
couldn't defeat and that person is Louis
Paulsen more if he had a terrible score
against paulsen
of all the games they played they played
a eight games in classical time format
Louis Paulsen won't fine get five games
morphe won only one and they drew two
games and even a great chess force today
Magnus Carlsen has a nemesis and his
name is John DePalma she Carson and
young played this is their eighth game
so far in classical chess and young for
a young won four games and they drew
four games so Magnus Carlsen never
defeated young upon yashi in classical
time format so let's see this let's see
this game Carson has the white pieces
and he plays Knight to f3 and okay the
karlsen's defense he's been sick for
three days now and the his game against
Hikaru was a was a lost endgame that he
managed to save with a draw he was lost
against Michael Adams he managed to win
that game but that's just because he's
such an unstoppable force but here he
faces young upon Miyaichi and such moves
will not be tolerated see five men upon
Miyaichi we have a red already opening
see 3d 5d 4c capture sun d4c capture
Sundy for and Knight to c6 Knight to c3
Knight to f6 and Bishop to f4
nipple goes for Knights to h5 now
kicking that [ __ ] back
Bishop to d2 and here a very nice
psychological move Knight back to f6
saying to Carlsen
you know it's cool that you developed
your Bishop to f4 but I kicked it away
with 90 to h5 and you had to bring it
back to d2 to a much less active square
and now if Carlson would repeat Bishop
to f4 you know if
he were to bring it to a to an active
square once again a nipple would simply
repeat probably night to age five and
offer a draw but Carson has the white
pieces if he wants the window on the
chest classic he has to win this game
and unfortunately Bishop back to f4 is
not an option for him
so after Knight to f6 he played III and
okay it's already a small psychological
victory for Nippo making that Bishop
stand d2 and not being active on f4 e
six Bishop to d3 Bishop to d6 and E for
now D capture sunny for tonight captures
on e4 attacking the bishop and Bishop
back to e7 Carlson castles and epic
castles and Queen to c2 and we have h 6h
6 is a very useful move as the Queen and
Bishop were eyeing that h7 pawn now the
pawn is n h6 it will no longer be a
target in the future also it stops
either of the Knights from jumping to g5
rook a to be one Bishop to d7 a3 now
stopping this night from ever
infiltrating with Knight to be for
harassing the bishop in the queen roped
the c8 Knights the c3 a6 Queen to c1 and
we have rook to e8 rook F to e one
Bishop to f8 and we have now Bishop it
back to f4 and okay Acosta now has his
Bishop on f4 b5 Queen to d2 and d4 a
captures ninth characters and Knight to
e5 nepo captures Carlson's Bishop on d3
it's a very strong Bishop and Knight
captures Queen captures and a5 now and
if you look at this position it's a it's
a pretty cool position Carlson's pieces
are a bit more active a bit more towards
the center and napal napal has a NAPA
has a bishop pair but it's a very uh
nected bishop pair this Bishop on d7
isn't really doing much the bishop on f8
is definitely not doing much it's kind
protecting g7 but at the moment g7
doesn't really need protection
so Carlson plays Queen to f3 and here
neppo gets a brilliant idea how to you
know get rid of the only probably the
only weakness in his position and it
the bishop pair nipple plays Bishop to
b4 now painting the night we have rook
to e3 on pinning with a nice rock lift
and now Bishop captures and c3b captures
on c3 and now Bishop to a for this
Bishop comes into the game would a
temple on the rook rook to a1 was played
attacking the bishop and now Bishop to
see - and now nepo is getting this
Bishop from d7 to a4 - see - and now
eyeing f5 and from f5 it will be a very
active piece h3 across the nose what
neppo is doing and is preparing G for
Bishop to a5 now neppo is very satisfied
with his Bishop on f5 and if Carson
wants to kick it away he will have to
weaken his King King's position with g4
Carson doesn't mind g4 a question - h7
but even on h7 it's a it's an incredibly
active piece it's slicing the board in
half and also controlling b1 so Carlsen
can never put a rook on this very nice
open B file c4 now by Carlson and Knight
to d7 by nepo it seems like Carson just
wondered this d4 pawn but actually he
didn't if nipple would capture at Queen
captures on d4 then rook to d1 I have to
remove the Queen but she captures on h6
getting back the pawn if you capture
then Queen captures on f6 it's a it's a
winning game for Magnus Carlsen
so after c4 nipple play Knight to d7 and
here we have a terrible move by Carlsen
continuing with something like c5 would
definitely give Carson the advantage and
you know it would be it would be a great
game for him he would probably continue
pushing and in the end probably win the
game I mean this is a position Magnus
enjoys playing but like we said maybe
maybe Carlsen thought that net I mean he
didn't think Knepper would capture on
before that would be ridiculous
but he's been sick for the last three
days I mean in all the photos in all the
interview he gives you can see and here
he's really sick Knight to d7 by nipple
and now Carlsen place
Knight to c6 with a temple on the Queen
and this simply doesn't work a Nepalese
Queen to f6 and here we have Knight
captures on a5 seems like a culture
cousin wanna pawn but we have nice to be
six now attacking the c4 pawn and this
is this is where things really go wrong
here Carlson played the c5 and this is a
this is simply this one to do netbook
plays rook captures on c5 and now if you
capture the rook Queen captures on a1
would check but really I mean
Nepos said in an interview after the
game that he was expecting Queen to be 7
in this position but actually Carlsen
decided to capture the rook
he played D captures on c5 Queen
captures on a1 which checked King King
to hh2 and now Queen captures on a5 and
in this position the only realistic move
for Carlson is to capture C captures on
b6 getting back the piece and after
Queen captures and b6 he would be down
upon and would a slightly weaker Kings
position but you know it's it's not a
lost game yet you're you're the world
champion you have to you know you have
to make us believe anything is possible
but then again we have to take into
account that he's he's been sick for the
past three days and I've also said this
isn't in an interview Nepos said that he
knows in his own experience that when
you're sick you simply can't give your
best
so after Queen to a5 Carson played Queen
to c6 now he thought about getting a
temple on the rook and after the rook
moves only then capturing the night but
here comes the problem and this simply
loses the game immediately for Carlsen
Queen to a4 now attacking the Queen also
protecting the rook and if you capture
the knight now with the Queen then Queen
captures Bishop on f4 with check your
down a piece and you're losing this game
so after Queen to f4 Carlson was forced
to capture the Queen Queen captures on
a4
Knight captures on a4 and now simply c6
this pawn it's a very nice boy
it's very nice best bone it will even be
protected by the bishop when it reaches
c7 but nice to b6 c7 now and after f6
preparing c5 to block the bishops
defense of the c7 pawn rook to b3 would
an attack on the knight Knight the c8
and in this position Carlsen simply
resigned to the game as there is no way
I mean he's down a piece a full piece
with no compensation whatsoever the c7
point is nice but it's no compensation
and like I said in this position magnus
carlsen resigned again and this is a
nickel miasha's third win in a row in
this tournament and he's now in clear
1st place half a point ahead of Fabiano
caruana and this is this is definitely
his tournament Carlsen really yeah I
mean she's been sick for the past three
days and the past three days he's been
playing bad chest I mean it's not a bad
chest for any of us that's brilliant
just but for him it's bad chess so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I'm sure I'm sure Carlsen didn't and he
was it was a very upset when he gave an
interview to Maurice it wasn't even an
interview whatever Maurice asked him he
was not very interested when Maurice
Maurice asked what happened here cousin
just said I you saw everything you know
what happened and when Maurice asked him
what are his thoughts about tomorrow's
game cousin just said that he doesn't
have any thoughts about tomorrow's game
and he doesn't really care about
tomorrow's game but you know that's just
I always say things happen and but to
this day Jonnie pom Miyaichi remains
Coulson's undefeated name is nemesis and
the result is four wins and four draws
in the poem miasha's favor so that's the
game I would like to thank Diego kenapa
Misha
I'll serve our Julio Julio echeverria
and Mark Morris for contribution to my
channel I think a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here and one very
important
announcement the founder of deep mind
the Alpha zero you know you've been
checking out lately on my channel watch
one of my videos and retweeted it on
Twitter and he said that it's it's a
very nice video recommended as the
people so I'm very happy about that
you know demis hassabis i probably will
never see this video but thank you sir
thank you a lot so yeah thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon